you're talking about enlightenment
you're talking about ego death you're
talking about
all these things whereas like the people
who actually brought this to the table
were people who don't even take the
psychedelics
like the yogis the uh buddhists and
all these other people man when someone
takes
uh one of these things an intoxicant we
just call it an intoxicant
all right but we could refer to it in
all the different subcategories that
fire mentioned in the beginning
what it's doing is it's altering our
neurochemistry
like our neurotransmitters it's altering
the levels that of which
they are expressing or deep or
suppressing themselves
which causes you allah gives us a very
nice description
of what will be in jannah you know and
then he says
which one of your lord's favor will you
deny right
so allah subhanahu has given us uh some
kind of delayed gratification so for
for us as muslims of course we're not
perfect we have so many mistakes may
allah forgive us but the
overall understanding is that we try to
wait
we try that doesn't mean that we're not
going to eat or you know have intimacy
in this world yes
but it's not like open and do whatever
up for grabs right
so as the process of some said dunya
this is kind of like a restriction a
jail for the believer because you can't
just do what you want whenever you want
you know
we can't just eat what we want we can
just eat whenever we want once ramadan
you cannot right
you have to pray you cannot just sleep
whenever you want to there's certain
restrictions right
that's for the anonymous so he does
whatever or she does whatever
the heck they please whenever they
please right well it's like god says
okay you can
you can eat anything you want you can
have anything you want just don't
have from this street don't have the
forbidden fruit and
it's like people will say oh wow that's
right so in jenna you have all these
beautiful things yes wine
yes there is you know spouses uh
women yes there is food yes there is
fruits
you know you just recline you just pull
your you kind of comes down to
there's everything
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to t3m
we are still joined with gabriel
or romani and brother you're
[Music]
yeah it's uh 6 p.m ish where we are
right now
i just got my first meal of the day and
i know anna got a meal recently too
what'd you eat
[Music]
hours man i have to get my second meal
in
hey guys uh fasting intermittent fasting
or what i'm doing intermittent fasting
yeah
i'm supposed to be in a calorie surplus
this is not good for me man
yeah dude i'm just gonna make you a
diaper i'm just eating
[Music]
it is 7 a.m 7 a.m so are you currently
in a fasted state or did you eat
breakfast
uh i didn't eat yet no alhamdulillah man
drink some water that's the way to go do
you usually do that water with lemons
is that what you usually do um okay and
basically what i do is i try to stop
eating around
um eight seven thirty
seven depends a p.m and then try to
not eat for about 12 to 13 hours like so
i have my breakfast maybe like nine a.m
something like that
so it's kind of like intermittent
fasting kind of like enemies it's kind
of but not
so not so you know not so strict
yeah masala
just out of curiosity okay i'm
there is no diet just uh third i just
followed that soon
one third like i don't overeat i eat
everything try to go
low not low but cut some of the carbs
that are
unnecessary like i try to just keep the
carbs lows and the sugars well that's it
but i still do i still eat bread i love
bread you know romanian
but because i feel in my experience i'm
dealing with a lot of diets a lot of
people are counseling
uh a lot of people change their of
course their life habits and if people
do that that's great if they can keep
the
the the discipline you have then they
find purpose in that that's great you
know what i mean honduras i'm not to
refute that
but it's just i felt that a lot of
people quit after some time
it's you know so they do they get very
religious about it they get very strong
on it
one month two months and they're like
man you know they just have that one
slip and then it's just it's finished
you know so
for me i i everything is as long as
highland
as long as i don't need a late at night
and i exercise enough
and just yeah just try to do that night
fast
like i just let my body rest throughout
the night at least 12 hours or so
without eating there's no eating like
late sometimes i mean i have to be
honest you know sometimes like
my wife will make something crazy at
night and i'm like ah you know what
cheese day so it's all good like but but
it's okay like it doesn't affect me you
know what i mean like hamdillah
so it's good i'm i'm very comfortable
with
with what i do so gabriel how do you
know when
you are getting full okay
um so obviously you cannot measure like
a third like exactly right
exactly yeah i followed in arabic it
basically like it's an estimation
so you should never feel like as the
hadith process and it should never fill
the stomach right so that's the worst uh
vessel that you can fill as the prophet
sam said
and um you basically
yeah you just don't you never have that
pressure
on you right where you're like oh you
know you kind of recline back and you're
like man this is too much right
so you can estimate your blood your body
kind of tells you okay like i'm feeling
now that i'm you know it's like wow you
know it's too much so i think when you
when you lay back and you're like oh
that was good right that's like
you're full right so you can you
estimate you know so you eat enough
you know a portion you know you drink
water
you know it's a process you said a third
for air you breathe some people like
literally don't you know they don't
breathe they just like
you know binge eat you know yeah yeah
just just take it easy like though
so do you do you eat slow do you eat
fast do you moderate
i i guess um that's one of my mistakes i
do eat quite fast just because of
the i'm kind of in a rush a lot which is
bad it's not good it's not good to eat
fast
yeah so like i do travel a lot sometimes
i will
find myself eating in a car sometimes
here and there so it's not good
that's that's one big mistake so my
advice to people is like kind of take it
easy you know but don't spend like an
hour eating you know but just you know
if you're eating not so much you're
eating nice portion
you can finish it uh quite fast but
don't rush you know
yeah but i love food i mean food is good
you know as long as you you
you eat to to live but
uh you can also enjoy some of the food
like the processor used to love the you
know the shoulder of
you know of the sheep and you know
certain foods that he loved you know
what i mean that he likes so there's
this is like
it's organic you know when you look at
the left process and like it was not
like a monk life you know
it was just organic like everything was
organic like you just lived you know
it's just normal
there's no monk type of behavior you
know it's like you like things if you
had it he ate it if you didn't he didn't
you know if he didn't like something he
didn't eat it he didn't criticize it but
hadith said that he just didn't he just
left it you know i kind of didn't eat it
because many people were offering things
and whatnot so but he would never be
like oh that's not good i don't like
this you know sometimes we do
so it was just very very organic like
very nice
you hear left and right about uh how the
fruits of this world are not going to
compare to jannah
the foods the drink so why don't you go
a little bit into that if you have some
type of
you know research and study on that
because i'm sure that a lot of viewers
that don't know
they're like what do you mean there's
going to be wine there's going to be
drinks there's going to be fruits yeah
it's going to be sex
i know that i remember talking to some
christians you know we were doing a
discussion at the university
and um it was like a debate right and
they're basically
their accusation was like my god you
know
in the quran it says that you will have
horuline and you'll have this and
there's all this
physical type of experiences in
heaven how is that heaven should be
spiritual i'm like wait
i said should who says what should be in
heaven who are you to
you know to tell us what should be in
heaven i said what's your evidence you
know
that's a beautiful thing about islam you
know allah subhanahu
wa challenges humanity
bring your truth your proof if if you
are truthful
right don't just say stuff you know
people say stuff i think
it should be like this i think jesus is
god
i think you know this is that and i'm
just like you think
that's one thing good you think
therefore you are right
but that does not make correct you know
what i mean
so they're saying stuff like wow you
know you guys can have wine in there
and you know as one of the uh the dua
said he says
yeah we have it in jen you guys have it
in this world you're not gonna have it
in general
or in the afternoon i mean some people
like they talk about like oh why is
there
you know [ __ ] or food or wine
or this or that in jannah and like they
have a problem with it but in this world
they don't have a problem taking it
you know and they're they're over over
doing it you know
committing zinna doing all kinds of
stuff and thinking it's okay
right so for us we there's a certain
discipline that we have in this in this
dunya in this world
and because the effects of it
in this world are negative in many cases
right
as for jannah we know the prophet saws
i'm told it's very clearly described in
detail
that the wine of jannah is not like the
one in this world there is no
intoxication
and that's why muhammad it's
something that covers your intellect
okay so there is no such effects
in jannah there is no such defect of
overfilling there's no effects of
there's just all those negative things
do not
exist in general it's not because we say
so or we're trying to
justifies because the process i'm
clearly explained
in surah rahman which is a very
beautiful surah
55 in the quran allah gives us a very
nice description
of what will be in jannah you know and
then he says
which one of your lord's favor will you
deny right
so allah has given us uh some kind of
delayed gratification like
were you gonna get this reward and we
know there are so many psychological
studies
um what are called longitudinal studies
that have followed
children who are offered i think it's
called the the marshmallow
uh you know experiment where kids were
given you know he said you can have one
uh you know
one now or like three later right and
they keep like no i want no one now
right
and most of the world is is hedonistic
right they want to satisfy their desires
now right but they don't understand what
can be the consequences of doing that
as for those kids who delayed the reward
what happened is this the the
researchers followed them throughout
their life and they found them to be
much more successful
in making choices career stuff like that
right
so for for us as muslims of course
we're not perfect we have so many
mistakes may allah want to forgive us
but the
overall understanding is that we try
to wait we try that doesn't mean that
we're not going to eat or
you know have intimacy in this world yes
but it's not like
open and do whatever up for grabs right
so as the prophet saw some said
dunya this is kind of like a restriction
a jail for the believer because you
can't just do what you want whenever you
want you know
we can't just eat what we want we can
just eat whenever we want once ramadan
you cannot right
you have to pray you cannot just sleep
whenever you want to there's certain
restrictions right
that's for the anonymous so he does
whatever or she does whatever the heck
they please whenever they please right
so that's the difference right so in
jenna you have all these beautiful
things yes wine
yes there is uh you know spouses uh
women yes there is uh food yes there is
fruits
you know you just recline you just pull
your it kind of comes down to you
there's everything and then as the
prophet saws said only the names of
these things
are like kind of what matches uh gender
as allah says
why because that's there's a connection
like in education you make connections
between different knowledge so you can
understand
better so there's a connection between
the names so we understand that there is
something wow you know bananas taste
good wow
a mango stays amazing right can you
imagine
that the ones in general are going to be
so much more that only the names apply
like
so write your mind right away you're
almost like oh my god i can't wait
right so you say oh my god i can't wait
you kind of like you know so then
i don't have to really rush in this
dunya or make a mistake in this
i can just try to hold myself and just
take it easy or just
take what's allowed only from what allah
has given us because again allah doesn't
allow us to starve in this dunya you
know because people think like again
oh my god islam is so difficult there's
so many rules
actually if you think about it there
isn't so many rules actually by default
everything is halal except if allah
or the prophet said so right but it's
not so yeah it's it's a great thing i
mean i'm looking forward to i don't know
about other people but it's great you
know
so bro what about people who would uh
raise the counter arguments saying okay
well if in jannah
there's gonna be these things but we
have it here right now why not just do
it now
obviously we have our beliefs but like
what about these people
yeah i mean allah has put these things
for us even in this dunya
so okay there's food in this dunya so
allah is not you know he says
doesn't burden a person more than they
can bear right so allah has made you
know food this that
women whatever in this world right man
whatever it is right
so you have two options
so you can take food allah didn't tell
you don't eat right
you know right allah says
eat from it right um we go to the story
of adam and eve right
so
but don't come close to this one tree
only one and and kind of that is how
dunya is almost like too right there's
just so many things
like it's halal but there's some
exceptions so
allah subhana tala uh you know like he
says
as you please as you want there's
plenty abundance right he told adam and
eve
and his but he says but this tree don't
get close to it
right and allah subhana tala you know
it's not a cliche
statement to say that this dunya is a is
a test
so he has given us food there's meat
there's this there's that there's
chicken there's
fruits every single fruit pretty much i
don't know of anyone that is haram
everything is pretty much halal you know
except for you know pork right and
certain things
um like predator animals certain animals
specific that we don't really
are going to eat you know what i mean um
other than that like
everything is halal you know okay women
are they not halal yes
uh it's you want one okay just have to
do what the process
i said two witnesses you know you make
the nikah hijab kabul
your wally whatever and you uh you know
you get married
you don't you're not good with one take
two you're not good with two take three
you're not good with three take four
it's all good you know what i mean so
allah subhana has given us something but
there's certain limitations if you look
at the limitations
they're not so much it's people's
mentalities when they come into islam or
they look at islam
or they're conditioned again we talked i
think yesterday about conditioning
by society to feel like oh my god you
know it's like
the scarcity type of mentality we have
we don't have
everything's haram everything is not
allowed everything is this it's not
everything is okay like things are just
very nice right so
you can you know choose money around and
make money or you can steal or
take riba or interest or whatever you
want everything is available
but allah subhanahu has put this test on
us just do it according to what i told
you
i've given you plenty of options take
that right
then if you insist to take the haram
option then that is a punishment there's
a sin
right so there's allah has given us
that's why you know
we say
right god give us in this world good
things the best things hasanah you know
uh and in the hereafter right and this
is the the best
right if we look in that surah so
alhamdulillah you know allah is that's
why
you know he didn't like i don't know it
didn't make it so
difficult it is a test there is
difficulty
i know there's a lot but
again in general if we start things on a
clear slate
on a clean slate um it is
good that's why the sharia has been set
in such a way that sometimes a bit
strict
because human beings as they you know
children
we're oblivious as we develop when we're
little we need protection
sometimes our parents fail to protect
because they don't understand they don't
practice
so then society protects you the sharia
protects you the law protects right
people are fighting the sharia and allah
yet look what's happened look where our
societies are going the decadence
immorality and so on people have a
problem they say oh the sharia is so
strict
but it's for a reason to protect the
developing
soul so that it takes a natural pathway
of development
without being you know conditioned
towards
the wrong things like i'm sure i'm not
sure how many of your
converts i know angel is convert right
like
the thing is people like myself and
angel you know growing up we didn't
necessarily know what's right and wrong
so we're in a different situation maybe
in terms of
you know what we tasted in the past and
it's quite difficult for
people like us to you know to
to move through the world it's tough
it's not impossible
but it's much tougher by someone who's
been protected by the sharia for example
and parents and family and they kind of
just growing
up naturally you know they might have
mistakes here and there be exposed to
certain things obviously in the world
but i don't know i'm not gonna talk
maybe not talk about anger but talk
about myself
like when i grew up you know i was
exposed to all kinds of things and
no one said oh yeah but it's wrong you
know like my dad would be like yeah you
know
get the girls man you know you've got to
represent you know what i mean gotta
represent
the family legacy stuff like that right
so it's different right from a father
who would tell you like no brother you
know you got to take care you got to
protect yourself from marriage this is
an issue of ethics of morality
of you know building a family you know
is different you understand how
the sharia has a purpose of protection
so it's much
difficult for people like us but we can
do it
you know allah has given us you know
enough to to be able to to be happy so
it's a test and inshallah allah make it
easy for us to pass you know
life is short man life is very short i
mean bro
that reminds me man i'm just gonna play
doubles out for a bit because you said
there's a lot of things here that
are hello uh except what's haram but
obviously the other side the opposing
they're gonna look at it like oh
everything's
wrong so a lot of people might be like
okay
there's and for those of you that don't
know what i'm gonna talk about we'll
explain in a bit but
we talked about drugs before but
specifically
there's this increasing new wave on on
these things called psychedelics
now when i say increasing as in this
bringing it into the light of legality
or at least proposing it to be brought
into the light of legality
because at least from my understanding
in canada and the states most of these
things are illegal
and in most places in the world i'm
talking about things like
shrooms acid you know lsd
dmt these types of things and a lot of
people believe it or not have taken
these things and have had spiritual
experiences
right so they have these enlightenment
you know or
subjective self-proclaimed enlightenment
they have these things where they're
like oh i had an ego death and now i'm
more connected with the universe i'm
more present but
allah tells us very plain and simple any
intoxication any mind altering substance
we should be forbid from so what do you
what do you have to say to these people
okay yes as the process and told us
right that um
and it's a very important principle in
sharia because you
extend that ruling to anything that kind
of changes your mind
um and we'll talk a little bit about
that it's just not just like you know
black and white just like that because
there are certain you know issues that
can be looked at
um however you know the word
psychedelics i mean psycho
psyche from the soul okay or it's a
greek term
of of having mind manifesting
so basically um you know allowing your
mind they say to reach its true
potentials or unlocking
the true potentials of the mind and many
things that many people have talked
about that you know
i think recently also jordan peterson
talked about it
uh others have talked about it brian
rose from london real he had you know
quite a few guys that he brought in
talking about psychedelics and he's gone
through the amazon and
and you know and tried it and whatnot
and these are these guys are the
proteges of dan pena and
all these guys and a lot of these
coaches and life coaches and you know
people are just
taking out or challenging life and the
the status quo and the normal
you know the the standards and just
developing themselves right
so of course the world is looking at
some of these guys and it's all
propaganda again right
uh they're looking at these guys and
seeing that you know
kind of tying him into masculinity and
we talked about yesterday
there's a lot of people are sitting
there wishing they could or they could
do things and
they would have done things in their
lives they're sitting in their
comfortable
a he said that
there will be my time in my um where
people will be reclining on their couch
you know like couch potatoes
right people are sitting there
comfortable and they're you know opening
netflix
opening uh you know social media and
they're seeing these
this rise of men who are saying you know
what screw everything we're gonna like
experience life we're gonna challenge
everything
um you know we're just gonna go out
there and do it right so
look at the performer on the screen the
guys were actually doing it which is a
very very small percentage
who are taking a leap and they're
becoming courageous to do something
about their life and they're just not
accepting the nine to five
slavery type of lifestyle and uh so the
other ones
99 of the people these are maybe one
percenters you know the 99
and they're in the one percent 99
percentile the other ones the 99
they're looking on the other side of the
screen they're saying man you know wow
look at this guy's a real moab
you know so they're being you know
they're reading the books they're these
guys are selling the books these guys
the one percenters are
are selling their shows they're getting
the followers and whatnot
they're going around the world filming
everything and the rest of the world is
kind of sitting there wishing they could
be there right they wish
they could be like them or be them
so there's a lot of conditioning and
that takes place so
there are studies there are research
there is research on these drugs
bottom line is bro that see when you
alter your state of mind
what happens is just like when you're
depressed or when you're not in your
real
you know state of functioning you open
yourself
you're susceptible stronger or more to
the influences of shaytan right so
people
experience having these like
enlightenments and you know
they'll con certain terms
and then obviously people are like oh my
god ego death and this
and that wow you know but if you're like
what does that mean
like how do you know how can you how can
you qualify that how can you quantify
that how can you gauge that
right people don't question sometimes
some of these statements they're just
like wow it sounds so amazing right
so yes there's been a lot of things have
been written
again recently and this is obviously
something that we can debate on
uh with the people are proposing these
kind of models
but i would say that is
the mind can be unleashed can be
unlocked
through enlightenment via knowledge
right and it is a spiritual
uh thing that you know is is experienced
through
revelation and through connecting with
the almighty through a clear path
like you know when allah
you know he has revealed you know the
quran right
he says
there is no doubt so i want to focus on
that there is no doubt
so the spiritual awakening that i've had
when i read the quran
is undoubtful because
i see i know i can understand i connect
well when you start smoking up or you
start taking certain things
there's a doubt in it there's a you
don't know where where are these
thoughts coming from
is so it's induced by the drug you
couldn't reach that enlightenment
through your own potential because now
you're getting external help
you can call it spiritual but again how
do you check whether it's spiritual not
just because you feel it's very
subjective
spiritual enlightenment visions this and
that
why is it not hallucinations see these
people again are thinking
from an even though their con is
spiritual is
substance is based on
it's it's materialistic and materialism
is linked to atheism in the end
right but it's like the external use or
the external intervention
of substances to help you to cope with
your
freaking misery that you're a freaking
loser and you need to
get some kind of you know substances to
help you of course
drink alcohol you get all of a sudden
different right because your mind is not
working the right way the way it was
supposed to work the way allah smith is
created allah didn't create you
with the need to drink alcohol or the
ability or you didn't
you know as soon as you imagine as soon
as you come out of your mother instead
of giving you some milk
she gives you a shot of whiskey or
something i know and all of a sudden
you're like oh that's the best right
and then no it's not you start drinking
milk you drink water you eat food
you develop natural it's only when
throughout life you go through this
misery of society there's always
conditioning you should be happy and you
should
be this and you should be that and you
should look like that and have a eight
pack
and have you know a back that looks like
this and women should look like that
then you start realizing man i feel
miserable right
and then instead of going for clear
undoubtful knowledge
of what your purpose in life is people
start
adventuring around and seeing things and
you know trying to experience things and
then they've you know
come upon different cultures that have
been doing
certain things as part of rituals in
their
you know religions or whatever it is um
through different encounters travelers
and so on and then like hey that
sounds pretty good like i mean these
guys are living somewhere in an
ammo in the forest they're not dealing
with
society's challenges yeah maybe they're
hunting maybe they have their own
internal politics
but it's not like living in the world
you know
as the prophets did it's not like living
you know and dealing with with the
issues the developments the fitna
all these things that we see and we read
throughout the quran
so then you're basically realizing that
oh my god you know maybe this is a
solution so
you're taking something external
injecting it
engulfing it whatever it is and then you
have this so-called
experience and then you you feel so good
because you kind of lost control
and losing control i mean a lot of
people like that
because for once in their life they feel
like they
they can silence some of the miserable
thoughts that they have or feelings or
insecurities
right and then they go out
to others and they start promoting it to
shows through books to this and that and
others get
so excited by and they're like wow you
know they start connecting it to
religion
start connecting with things and they
start even the muslims say well why is
it haram
because you get closer to god right i
mean it's the same type of thing
even a little bit different but what the
sufis you know used to do in islam
right like even dervish is just like
spinning around right if you ever try to
spin
okay 20 times you will feel that your
mind now because of the force that
you're using
is going you're going to feel dizzy
you're not feeling normal it feels good
actually it feels very good right so
you're spinning around and that's what
they used to think that
you spin around and that's where you get
a
this this unique connection with your
creator that no one else can do it you
know unless you come to this tariqa
and this way and you sit with the sheikh
they'll teach you how fast to spin how
to spin and
how to you know and then you're like the
the rational mind will say wait a second
the process
didn't do that he didn't spin
and try to get his mind into a state
where he gets to connect or have this
higher experience with his creator his
his connection with this creator was
salah
you know that's what he said
you know a lot of these people do the
drug
but they'll never wake up for camp they
never wake up half an hour one hour
before fajr don't have the strength they
need
some substance to help them to reach
you know some kind of state of
enlightenment so enlightenment is
through knowledge enlightenment is
through revelation
not through these substances that
change your disposition your mind yeah i
might feel good i'm not denying that
that it's not going to feel good
you'll find a thousand excuses and
definitely yours
you'll be very susceptible to shaytan
whispering
and human beings and other people you
know people forget that there's a lot of
sons of devils in this world who are
going to tell you take these things it's
good
i took it it's really good you know you
can have this amazing experience
so you know i i just don't don't see it
i'm not i'm i'm an intellectual i need
to be you know these arguments
make no sense they're nice they're
termed very nice a lot of movies a lot
of things a lot of money has been
invested in it
but to me it's like i put in the same in
the same basket as
lgbt as as promiscuity as many other
things alcohol
other problems in the world that people
want to silence
the reason in them and just kind of do
whatever the heck they you know
against what allah has created them yeah
i know i want to hear your experience on
it yeah i was just about to jump in bro
brother i think that was incredible
and i'ma just slide a few things in here
just to kind of
piggyback off what you're saying like
romney likes to say
so yes
when we take these things because i mean
obviously i was not a muslim my entire
life so
i have done a lot of things that you
know are bad
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna sit here and
say that i'm proud or anything but
when someone takes yeah man when someone
takes
uh one of these things an intoxicant we
just call it an intoxicant
all right but we could refer to it in
all the different subcategories that
fire mentioned in the beginning what
it's doing is it's altering our
neurochemistry like our
neurotransmitters it's altering the
levels that of which
they are expressing or deep or
suppressing themselves
which causes you to experience an
altered
state of being an altered state of mind
and that's why people experience what
they experience but it's like dude
you're talking about enlightenment
you're talking about ego death you're
talking about all these things
where it's like the people who actually
brought this to the table
were people who don't even take the
psychedelics
like the yogis the uh buddhists and
all these other people that are going
into
[Music]
the crazy stuff that you hear what
people are talking about when they
take psychedelics right so again we're
talking here that you take it
it's altering you know chemistry making
you feel this way but you can also feel
that
being a hundred percent sober and then
it's
it's almost like to say that
this psychedelic or this intoxicant is
uh the equivalent of the forbidden fruit
where it's like god says okay you can
you can eat anything you want you can
have anything you want just don't
have from this tree don't have the
forbidden fruit and
it's like people will say oh well if
this is altering my neural chemistry
and i'm experiencing these uh spiritual
experiences
then why can't i tell you was like bro
it says it very clearly in the book
it says it very clearly do not take
these and talk skins why
because because it's you should have
faith like it
if you believe the rest of the quran
why would you not believe that part you
feel me
where it's like if someone wants to
doubt that well then it's like you're
essentially doubting
the rest of the book and the rest of the
revelations and then if you go and take
the intoxicant yourself you will see for
yourself why the book was telling you
not to take the intoxicant and like bro
i wanna i just wanna throw in
one crazy thing here all right so you
know how
this is all referred to as the dunya
yes this is all the uh the simulation
the test
and um you guys ever watched these uh
these really fancy tvs that like it's so
high definition that when you're
watching the show it looks fake
it looks like you're you're there
watching them like record it
yeah yeah yeah so back in the day
when i did partake in these things i
remember it would put me in
in such a hyper present
state where i would look at things and
it's almost like i could
see how fake it all was it looked so
real that it looked fake
and i was like oh this is this isn't
real this isn't real and i kept telling
my friends like yo this isn't real
and then here i am bro i just wander
upon
the quran or or should i say i was
guided to the quran and then the quran
is saying that
this isn't real this is a test
this is the dunya and it's like again
why does it say it in the book because
it is the truth
yes so true and that's why like again
you know just the word hammer you know
like from himad it's something that
covers your
head and your you know your mind so it's
it's just
just that the concept of altering your
mind is is enough to make it haram and
a lot of people i think forget the
what's called the the first high you
know
a lot of people when they take drugs
they continue because the first time is
never like the second
time or the second time is never like
the first time and the third time is
never like the first time
you're going to continue and you're
going to try different ones and that's
why
people take psychotics or any kind of
drugs they don't stop at one kind
they're not like oh this is my path i
take this drug
you know whatever it be lsd or something
like that you know they're gonna be like
i take this and that's it
no they're gonna try and experience
other things because they're looking for
that first experience
and it doesn't happen so yeah someone is
to take it in their 20s they're going to
feel amazing ecstasy go to club brave
whatever
all that and thinking they're living up
but once they they reach
40 and 50 wait a second so what's
happening there how come now things are
different
uh how come like
just anything man like like steroids you
know what i mean it's just not part of
you you know my brother
you know died last year because of that
you know what i mean
and uh you know what was the issue with
him like he had this low self-esteem you
know he you know as a child he grew up
kids are making fun of him that he's
screaming
i could give a damn whether they you
know i was screaming i was the same he
was crazier than him but i think
just the way i looked at things were
different i couldn't care and
you know he was always like injecting
and he was always you know he was huge
and masha'allah looked amazing yeah but
his heart was only at 50 percent
he didn't know it so when he got a
little virus and he got infected
he go into the hospital he couldn't come
out you know his heart gave it
you know what i mean so yeah like people
need to look at this
issue from from many different
perspectives
not just the fact that oh yeah we're
gonna have this amazing
you know experience and connect
spiritually and
you know this this is all slogans to me
you know people really need to
become a bit deeper than that and you
know you got to take care of your body
this body isn't a man
allah is giving exactly everything you
need
but you need to have that motivation
is strong you know revelation is very
important
um helping each other like that's why
like
you know i think that we men
need you know support that's why there's
a concept of an
ummah that's why when we know four of us
talk it's like you feel amazing you know
because that tao
and that cooperation that support is so
important for male specifically you know
that's how we are we're always you know
soldiers of an army we were always
warriors for thousands of years we're
never just lone wolves you know
there's we're always together and and
pushing each other and encouraging each
other getting that high spirit you know
iman
and now we're alone right so yes i
believe that
it's important to have a high state
of mind awareness you know spiritual
high
but it comes natural it comes from you
know us talking to each other inspiring
each other reading
and seeking knowledge moving our bodies
eating well um having a purpose man
that's the whole point right like
i don't know like when i wake up like
today i was so
tired man i haven't been sleeping while
i told you guys i had the you know the
rib right problem
and i can't you know when you have like
a brokerage you can't really sleep
properly it's been like two weeks now
i'm that's much better now but i felt
like man you know but
when you have a purpose i'm like i gotta
do something i got something to do
this morning you know what i mean and i
think that's a problem a lot of people
don't have anything to do
so then just go back to bed and just
don't have a purpose so when you have a
purpose you have that high
motivation you feel like you're on a
mission you
i don't know it's just you do reach that
high
state of of of of you know iman of faith
of
existence of purpose and it does feel
amazing you know what i mean
and that's what's you know motivation
and iman right like you
get for a jog you start seeing the
change in your body
you you start reaching your goals uh you
know
you start having that self-talk you know
that the sahaba and the prosthetics
you know this this uh this you know you
basically it's very important a lot of
men don't know how to have self-talk
they don't know how to have that
internal dialogue
you know where you challenge yourself so
i think we have everything we need from
allah it's just a matter of
of doing it and helping each other
coaching each other
and i think one of you said that you're
coaching you know the other brother
right
that's the whole point right we're
supposed to you know something i don't
know i know something you don't know
and we cooperate and we work together
and i think
a lot of men are doing psychedelics and
they're doing
doing all kinds of weird stuff these
days you know hear all kinds of stuff
it's because they're lacking purpose
but their fitra their natural
disposition is
dynamic it needs to do it it's just like
it needs to move
it just doesn't know where to move
there's no guidance to to where to go so
it's always moving but it's like moving
back moving forward taking one step
forward two step backward
it's just kind of crazy right but for us
we know where we have to move you know
on the sirat and mustafi
gotta move forward you have a
destination and you're not just try okay
let me try this one let me try that we
have a clear print you know
and and it does change things it does
i mean i don't know i feel
i feel amazing i feel great
alhamdulillah praise be to allah like
i'm tired
sometimes i get problems there's issues
at work
this that i've been moving around the
world for the past you know
more than a decade but is
life is is beautiful man life is
beautiful
it's just amazing with all these
challenges and all the
ups and downs and this is just
amazing alhamdulillah you
man know agree 100 um
i can only speak from a male perspective
and say that like as men
we really do need purpose but i mean it
goes the same for
women you know because there are women
that are watching
these podcasts and like i get it you
know women need purpose too but like
speaking as a man like it's just
something else for us
and like you said it's in our did you
say fitna
yeah like our natural disposition our
dna you know
yeah yeah yeah okay understood so yeah
like
as a man like we we strive
so much to have purpose
that if we don't have purpose we seek
purpose and
all these other things whether it be um
playing video games non-stop
whether it be some random hobby or
whether it be
taking these intoxicants because it's
like you said it's like
when you're doing it because you're not
experiencing anything
so like essentially no one does
psychedelics
for actual knowledge and and growth and
wisdom they're doing it to experience
something
because what they're experiencing is not
enough
and if you don't have purpose then you
obviously aren't experiencing enough
rest like
when you were talking about how you're
doing martial arts
mashallah bro when you're sparring at
the end of that sparring session how do
you feel
yeah bro out of this world bro
out of this world and i feel like a lot
of men are lacking that and
not even just talking about the martial
arts but just
purpose in general and that's why like
that's why they stray to all these
different ways
that's right percent 100 100
i totally agree 100 alhamdulillah yeah
it's
it's um you know allah subhana tales has
given us
you know this amazing you know this
amazing purpose and
you know you said also about women i
like to add to that
that's true but you see i feel i feel
like adam was created first and there's
a reason for that
you know women don't like this talk but
when they realize that when they submit
to understanding the hierarchy then i
believe that again their fitra their dna
will function properly
so when men fix themselves then
naturally women
will have to fix themselves they align
you know
right now i i do blame a lot of men i do
work with a lot of men i get some
i get very tough with certain men and
call him out because you know and myself
as well i'm very tough with myself i'm
not saying that i was born like this and
i just lived my whole life on this
you know path i had times where i
slipped big time
you know but but if we fix ourselves
men that's why it is our responsibility
that's why adam was created first
i think naturally women will just fall
in line right now they're running around
loose
because we didn't fix our problems our
house is not in order
our issues as men are not in order so
that allows them
to mess about and then there as i think
one of you said right this negative
feedback right so they're messing about
messing us up and we becoming weaker and
there that allows them to mess about
even more
and the whole you know dynamics uh
changes you know and a lot of women are
realizing that that's the crazy
thing that's the amazing thing people
tell me bro what are you talking about
are you kidding me you're gonna get
either arrested or something's gonna
happen someone's gonna stab you whatever
you know what and i'm like but i don't
see i see women coming around
and saying you know what is so right
i as much as it is so right you know and
they start
looking like for this kind of man that
we are
you know talking about you know this
kind of model the the muslim
alpha man the khalifa type of you know
guy who is going to be the leader
who's going to be the strong man you
know yet he's he's not
uh you know doing injustice he's not
doing dorm
and there's this is because it's part
it's inside it's buried in their dna so
women have to also have a purpose no
doubt but it's not the same as men
and i think that's a problem we have
left a huge void in this dunya
as men so now all these empty spaces
women are starting to fill them in
you know what i mean so now they're
finding purpose and being out there you
know being like a
soldier or something i just saw this uh
report where there was a training uh
there was a training uh program in the
desert
for like three months you know men and
women training to be marines and
sadly i mean at all levels women
significantly if you know science and
statistics significantly means like a
huge difference
underperformed okay compared to men why
why are you there in the first place you
know why are you there just to prove
that you got to be like men or that we
are
you know not doing our job or whatever
you know you have
your niche where allah has created you
with certain skills that are just
beautiful
you know i know women will be like oh my
god what is this chauvinistic type of
speech but that's what it is i'm very i
stand by
you know raising children man it's like
nurturing
human souls what more
beauty and and purpose do you want than
that you know like
can you we cannot men men don't we we do
it but we're not as
like it's we can't do it the way a woman
does
and i was looking at the word nurture we
are educating our children we need to
especially our boys
we fathers have a huge role but the
woman
has this divinely given gift
that she hates now she's been made to
hate by the feminist movement by the
lgbqt
and and they hate when you say even just
the me
saying you should be a a mother a
housewife
and you should find purpose in that
beauty of
of taking care of this cradle that's
going to
nurture generations of warriors to come
righteous men
and good women righteous women
they hate that they're like why and they
don't know why
you know they're only going to find out
why when they're 45 and 50
and they're alone and they start have to
join stuff like you know trad wives
movements
you know and subhanallah the non-muslims
are waking up
the african women are waking up and
saying
what the heck have we done what have we
done oh
girls young girls and you're 15
14 who are watching netflix being
conditioned
don't do the same mistakes we have done
check it out sisters check out
the the traditional wife movement yeah
people are fighting in this and that but
that's the reality check out what the
african sisters are saying waking up
and saying man you know colonization and
and then westernization is destroying
our men destroying our families
they're promoting polygeny bro african
christian sisters are
big big you know promoters of of
religion and then you have you know
these uh you know i are
our sisters who are you know what is it
like a salafi feminist you know
uh you know who's getting all the
you know writing articles for muslim
matters or whatever you know and then
you know
trying to if it doesn't work religion if
you know people are
going back forth trying to attack trying
to smash it
it's not about that or this man it's
just about the what's going on
in the world you know women need to find
purpose
in what allah created them to find
purpose and men need to find purpose
in what allah has given them the skills
to find purpose
and as much as we're going to fight that
we're never going to be happy
because you're not it's like wearing
shoes that are tight you know if you
have a
like abscess i'm size 12 and a half you
know
like if i wear size 11 or 11 now even 12
is going to
rub me i'm not going to be able to
perform properly
but you're wearing shoes bro be happy
that's what people say
but you have a life you have one you
have you're okay
yeah but i can't function properly but
you have one wife but you're okay
i can't function properly bro because
it's not what
fits me you know what i'm not everyone
wears size 12 you know half shoes or
whatever
but if you're gonna wear size 11 on a 12
and a half foot
you can function properly you're gonna
wear pants that are too tight you can't
move properly
you can't you know you can't so
people just need to realize that allah
has created us in a certain way
and we can you know excel
in that field and that field is quite
vast it's quite vast we don't have to
get
out of it and be like well let me see
what the girls are doing on their side
oh i think i should wear some of these
you know uh you know clothes and start
you know do my nails or something like
that because i find purpose in that
you're confused man
confused that's why the scholars
define this homosexuality and these kind
of things because confusion
you know people are confused they're
crossing over on the other side you know
they're confused you know people are
facts man nice all the things you said
so far i just want to know some of them
so
we don't even have to have that thing
you were talking about people have
differences opinion or
i feel this or i feel like heaven
shouldn't be this see that's subjective
if you guys just
just stop talking sit back and just look
at reality look at history
you could see that just like brother
gabriel said all of men
all of the prophets where men were
naturally leaders and for women that are
like okay
um why should women be the nurturers why
should women do this i could work a job
too i could be a ceo too i could own
that company too
yeah but look at look at look at the
natural state that y'all are
in you a kid grows in you a baby grows
in you
a baby needs and you are naturally by
virtue of being
a biological woman the only one capable
of raising and nurturing that kid while
it's inside you i can't do that gabriel
can't do that angel can't do that
rami might be able to do that now i'm
playing romney can't do that too bro i'm
just throwing a stab at you because it's
been almost 40 minutes and you haven't
said anything so far
so either you're super you know
saturated with thoughts or you got
no thoughts but either way i'm gonna let
you you know do your you do your
contribution soon because
you know it's only fair um yeah so it
makes
it literally makes no sense when women
are like oh come on like why should i be
the nurturer
it's like i can you were made to do that
and i was here
i'm here as a man because a woman my
mother
decided to you know have a kid and she
got pregnant and she nurtured me
so it literally makes no sense you
yourself
the woman you wouldn't be here if your
mom didn't nurture you
and do that so come on you want to know
what it is
um women are out here trying to be mulan
and guys are out here trying to be white
knights
100 and and netflix
i know there's a lot of there's a lot of
uh movies like you know
cuties and all this stuff and it's it's
basically this
narrative that the the eastern woman is
oppressed
the muslim woman is oppressed and
western
ideology is the only thing that can free
her and liberate her
because there's this narrative that they
need liberation and then they do all
these things and then they
dye their hair purple and they shave
their heads and they go out with
their armpits hairy and you know wearing
dresses like wearing clothes like a man
and then they're 40 and then they're
like yo
i've been cucked by society i'm wrong
this is
this is not the way but it's like you
spend the last 20 years
telling other women who are more
vulnerable and at a young age and more
you know higher neuroplasticity to adopt
that type of propaganda
and it just it just leeches it just it
just goes from them
uh i i don't mean to cut in here and
unfortunately i did not contribute very
much today but uh my classes started so
i do have to go unfortunately
um brother gabriel may love bless you
voila it's been a tremendous honor the
amount
i've you know been able to reflect on
and learn just the past uh 24 hours is
amazing so may allah you know reward you
habibi
bless you bro good luck with your class
man because
it's it's through classes it's through
your research through your science
through your understanding and
an experience bro that you're able to
contribute what you do to our podcast
so keep doing you stay on your path keep
seeking knowledge
and by the grace of allah you're going
to contribute to a podcast more than
me and anger are doing in that aspect so
yeah you go
i really i really like uh you know you
guys man mashallah you guys are
this this is podcast it's just so
natural you know it's so organic you
know
it's like we're just chilling and just
talking you know i like it you know
sometimes certain things are so like
scripted like hey brother what do you
think brother
so yeah i like i like this very cool it
feels natural
that was the goal yeah all right god
bless you all
well again it was an honor i'll tell you
something
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hmm